You and I,
we share African ancestry.
Yeah.
I was shocked.
I'm 1.6%.
All right.
Yeah.
See I have more,
uh,
I have more credential than you in that department.
You're 2% right.
Yeah,
I know.
And it's,
it's funny because,
uh,
you know,
you sort of have your,
the story in your family kind of like where he came from and everything mates.
And I always knew I was 25%,
you know,
Italian.
Uh,
and I knew that my family came from Sicily and in fact,
uh,
the,
the Rinella is that came from Sicily all seemed to become kind of established in
in the produce world.
Uh,
my dad was brought up in the south side of Chicago.
I'm 44 years old.
Okay.
So think about that for a minute.
My Dad was brought up in the south side of Chicago and he was raised by his
grandfather who is Sicilian and come from Sicily.
His grandfather delivered produce with a horse and cart.
Whoa.
In Chicago.
So,
yeah,
to have lived through that,
like to be brought up in a house where a guy like leaves in the morning and a
horse and cart to deliver,
produce an end to be alive.
Like to fight in World War II,
to be through the atomic era,
the advent of the Internet.
Right.
But I always knew that we had Sicilians when I did the genetic test,
what some of those,
at some point in time,
one of those Sicilians must have shot southward and cross the Mediterranean and
like had a hookup down there,
something,
well,
that was the history of Sicily in the first place.
Yeah.
Sicily if just being Sicilian in the first place.
There was so many people that were,
uh,
impregnated by the Moore's and by various people of West Africa and North
Africa.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I should've probably like always assumed,
but it just,
I hadn't thought about it.
Um,
another thing I was reading about this stuff,
and you might know more about it than I do,
is that when you do those tasks,
there's missing parts.
You know,
it does it like it captures what's there,
but there's could be a lot of there that's not captured just in a way that
chromosomes are,
you know,
inherited and passed down like it's not,
it's an incomplete picture.
Right,
right.
There could be influences.
There could,
there could be in your,
and it doesn't create a full picture of your lineage.
There could be lineages that are there that aren't represented in your
particular makeup.
How so?
Like what do you mean?
You know,
I hate to right off the bat,
get into somethings that I can't speak about any level of expertise.
I was just reading a piece and the piece I was reading had to do,
it was kind of a dissection of like what happened with Elizabeth Warren would,
she claimed we even going off about that on the podcast and I'm like a hundred
times more African than she is native American.
Yeah.
Well that's what I found.
I'm 10 times more or whatever.
But it was a piece about it.
It was a,
it was a piece in the times explaining like how to make sense of now that
everyone's doing these tasks,
like how to think about,
make sense,
these tests.
But,
but my understanding of it is,
um,
that you could have a lot of ancestry that just isn't captured in your genetic
code and the way that would be detected through the testing.
Meaning there could be ancestors.
It for what?
Cause you're inheriting half,
you know,
your Harrington chromosomes from each parent and,
and somehow you could have,
it could be an incomplete picture.
You could have ancestors that had come from all the,
you know,
whatever these,
these tests break out the world and do a hundred or some odd regions or zones
that there could be people from those zones who are in your lineage that are not
captured in your personal,
that are not captured in your genetic code.
That's so bizarre.
You would think it would all be in there.
So that's just a,
an incomplete measuring tool.
Is that what it is?
Or is it just actually not in there?
I Dunno.
You're going to have to have a dude on,
I'll listen.
You need to have a dude on and it,
and as I say,
I feel like I'm off on a bad start here,
man.
How much a neanderthal did it say less than normal.
Really less than average.
The,
uh,
the number,
like it said,
it gives you,
you did 23 and me,
right?
I can't remember.
I just remember it was less than average and you know,
and those things like our refined by how many people do them,
you know,
but it was less than average,
which bummed me out.
But I'm like,
is Harry is like a 13 year old,
like Norwegian girl?
You know what I mean?
So that didn't surprise.
Shocking then surprise me too much.